[Musique]
plusieurs fait d'hivers à Ha nous ont
ont été pour nous comme une gifle
notamment des personnes qui sont
décédées et qui n'ont pas été annoncé
comme décédés pendant plus de 2 ans
quand on a reçu ces gifes on se'est dit
mais on peut pas rester comme ça
visiblement il y a des gens qui euh sont
en situation de de mort sociale de
d'isolement complet et on a décidé de
cibler en particulier les plus de 80 ans
c'est plus de 80 ans il y en a 1600
agins euh et donc on a mis en place tout
un dispositif de lutte contre
l'issolement d'abord aller les voir
aller chez eux ensuite pour les cas les
plus compliqués une équipe de de
spécialistes avec des gériâres des
assistantes sociales et enfin
revitaliser le le voisin
ximité voilà on s'est mis en BR c'est un
peu un combat pour la
fraternité